good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this morning boris johnson says he will
lead the tories into the next election
despite the calls for him to go over
lockdown breaking parties in downing
street the pm has arrived in india this
morning but he's followed by the
backlash back home as the government
tries to delay a vote to decide if there
should be an investigation into whether
he misled parliament in just a minute
we'll speak to the education secretary
nadeem zahawi also this morning we'll
get the views of labour's west streeting
and the leader of the lib dems that's
the ed davey it is thursday the 21st of
april defiance under pressure boris
johnson arrives in india hoping to leave
partygate behind him
here in ahmedabad the prime minister has
just landed and he insists he will fight
the next general election as he seeks to
delay a vote back home over his conduct
around partygate
phone calls for special talks with
russia to evacuate mariopol as a top
ally of vladimir putin
putin says the last pocket of resistance
in the city will fall today
macro and le pen clash over russia
immigration and the cost of living as
the last remaining candidates in
france's presidential elections go
head-to-head
her majesty turns 96 a new image is
released in celebration of her birthday
johnny depp tells the court it was his
ex-wife who was violent and abusive and
not him as he gives evidence about their
relationship
clash over wimbledon's decision to ban
russian and bella russian players from
this year's championships as the tennis
world speaks out we're live at
wimbledon also coming up on the program
for you this morning wherever you're
watching us around the world we'll take
you to a glacier in iceland for a
first-hand look at the impact of climate
change ahead of earth day
[Music]
and find out why car parks in the new
forest are being closed as part of an
effort to save endangered birds
[Music]
hello everybody very good morning to you
the prime minister says he fully intends
to fight the next general election as
tory leader the pm insists he won't
resign after being fined by police for
breaking his own lockdown rules or put
himself forward for a confidence vote
mps were due to vote later to decide if
there should be an investigation into
whether mr johnson misled parliament but
the government is trying to delay that
vote until the police inquiry has
concluded and the full sue grey report
has been published
well as you know from uh bethel the pm
is several thousand miles away from
westminster this morning he has arrived
in atmabad in india just in the last few
moments or so
during the trip boris johnson is
expected to announce a new trade
agreement including creating almost 11
000 jobs in the uk
well i'm pleased to say the education
secretary nadim zahawi is with us this
morning got my new glasses on what do
you think very smart thank you very much
it's nice to see you um the pm just
saying that he's going to fight the next
election does he have your wholehearted
support he certainly does
if you look at what he's been focused on
making sure that
um the global fight against inflation
and the economic recovery is in place an
energy strategy
safer streets and of course dealing with
war in europe
on
all these issues the prime minister has
been leading at home and leading
internationally and this trip
to india uh we are announcing about a
billion pounds of uh i think deals
already done in place um 11 000
jobs a trade deal with the largest
democracy in the world
slated to be the third largest economy
by 2050 this is what i think your
viewers will want their leader to be
doing and that's exactly what he is
doing we'll come on to india if we may
but partygate is still the albatross
around the prime minister's neck why
doesn't he just put himself forward for
an investigation by the privileges
committee himself and have done
well i think
in many ways if you just step back a
second think about you know how we do
things in this country and actually an
exemplar to the rest of the world due
process is important and what we are
tabling today
is an amendment to say actually the
right chronology is that the police
complete their investigation
the cabinet office report the sugray
report is published and then parliament
can decide to refer this to the uh
privileges committee that is the right
way of doing this if you follow due
process if you uh
just want to play politics with this as
kierstama was sort of
found out yesterday because he
uh whether
probably inadvertently misled parliament
that you got over excited to start
accusing the prime minister suggesting
that the leader of the opposition has
misled parliament well uh david evan has
actually put a letter into the speaker
of parliament and you agree with him
well because he accused the
prime minister of something that he
clearly had no evidence of he's accused
the prime minister of attacking the bbc
for their coverage in ukraine the prime
minister did not do that and um
by accusing him of the dispatch box um
mistakenly he should come and apologize
all i'm saying to you is if you want to
play politics with this then you know
the shenanigans that labour are
attempting today is the root if you want
to follow due process then you allow the
police to complete their investigation
you allow the sue grey report to be
published and then the privileged
committee can look at that that is what
i'll be voting for today the amendment
is the right chronology and the right
way to follow due process or you could
just be the prime minister and say you
know what
i'll just refer myself to the privileges
committee and then all of this nonsense
that we're debating and taking up all my
valuable time i'll just put it in in
train but there is a police
investigation yeah there is already a
cabinet officer reports
which is already reported in some scale
well but we haven't seen the
bridge version right we haven't seen
this we've seen at least 50 fines and
all i'm saying to you is due process is
the right thing to follow i think you'll
find most of my colleagues who are
fair-minded um who believe uh in uh due
process will vote for the amendment
because it's the right thing to do you
know this is not the prime minister sort
of saying you know he's he's the prime
minister he said i'll come to parliament
and i will make a full statement he's
come to parliament after receiving the
fixed penalty notice
given a
wholehearted apology explained him
a pantomime game we're told in the 1920s
um just a few minutes i i think from you
know
those people who were present at the
meeting um the detailed questions
and and roger gayle is a a
friend and i believe he was there for
three minutes as he quite rightly uh
made clear uh with your interview but
those who were there for the full
meeting so actually the the price dealt
with the substance of the issue and
talked about the economic recovery we've
got a global fight against inflation
people watching this today are worrying
about the energy of course they
absolutely are and the party instead is
being damaged because of party gate um
up until
even before the prime minister was fined
uh 810 local council seats likely to be
lost in the local elections because
people don't trust the prime minister
that's 40 of all the seats that you were
um
putting candidates up for clearly this
is something you can't move on from
until the prime minister grasps it by
the horns well the fifth of may is the
poll that we should quote uh i was with
um activists in wandsworth
a few weeks ago and on the doorstep what
people are talking about is the low
council tax being delivered in onesworth
compared uh uh to lambeth and and uh
merton and other boroughs uh uh that are
labor-led um i'm not gonna let you take
me down that route you're gonna get me
an awful lot of trouble when it comes to
the uh a local election that's all i'm
saying what i'm really saying to you is
that ultimately uh uh people make a
choice for who they want uh to lead in
their uh local area government based on
delivery of services and value for money
but partygate clearly does matter you're
a polling man so let me quote you some
polls uh in fact you gov that you once
uh were uh owner of joint owner of uh
that's found that by two to one the
public wants him to resign that was just
after the party gate fine was issued
well as i said look there will be polls
on partygate there'll be polls on um you
know the global fight against inflation
the real poll that matters is the fifth
uh of may and actually
on the doorstep people want to see
delivery of services at um value for
money and that's what
conservatives are delivering in local
government and if if you care about uh
you know your council tax and make sure
that your your weekly bing collection
okay all the other things being
delivered for you then you vote
conservatives well i have got um some
more polls for you another yougov poll
talking about how well the government is
or isn't doing i think we can put it up
on on the screen there 72 percent think
that government is doing badly on
immigration 70 percent badly on taxation
68 badly on the nhs that was a yougov
so look on immigration um i think part
of the problem has been
three years ago we were only getting
about 300 people um crossing that that
treacherous uh illegal uh crossing
through the channel that's up to 28 000.
so that's uh something that we're
dealing with with the this historic deal
with uh rwanda which i think is the
right thing to do remembering that these
people
i do i tell you for why why because just
to remind our viewers of your background
you know you came here yes uh as a young
man you couldn't speak english you were
an immigrant yes uh if you did that
today yes you would be taken to rwanda
and even if you passed all the tests
you'd have to stay there you wouldn't be
able to come here yes but it's tiny
detail which is really important my
parents fed a dictator from iraq landed
in the first safe country which is
britain uh and made their life yeah but
hold on a second but we came through a
legal route and applied for immigration
status and and got that
these
people who are being exploited by
criminals are coming from a safe country
called france that they are already in a
safe country they are coming they're
choosing to be um putting their lives at
risk and being exploited by criminals we
have such a bad relationship with france
now we won't pay them well we still owe
them 52 million pounds that we've
promised to give to them in order to try
to help with refugees and we haven't
given it to you and the and the we are
grateful to john darms and the
intelligence sharing and you know
with that intelligence area has been
responsible for a number of of illegal
crossings being thwarted uh but it's
worth reminding viewers that actually
those illegal crossings also mean
capacity has been taken away from people
who may not be able to make those
illegal crossings who are legitimate
asylum seekers that we need to look
after and we've got a great track record
in doing that in that you know since
2015 i think we've um uh welcomed 185
000 uh people uh to this country from
afghanistan from syria from hong kong uh
and now from ukraine
as you know we've got a dedicated team
in the department of education where
we're looking uh to uh place children
from ukraine in the first trash about a
hundred thousand children is is our
game's not working very well though is
it well i'm very even
the former housing minister has said
that he that was it was very challenging
he's now taking in some refugees it was
challenging and and it continues to be
and we get better so you know one of the
things we learned very quickly is having
to go uh to a processing center and get
your visa physically uh was not
necessary you can do it online uh the
numbers are coming up we're almost
touching 60 000 uh people now um and of
course in education we're a tech savvy
you know first world country
it should have been much easier than
this
look we had to stand this up rapidly um
the the the home office stood up the
processing centers i think within
a week um and started processing the
first visa applications um
and people would that evening uh started
getting their uh visas through
we are
we have a very proud track record of of
certainly in my department of making
sure every afghan child is in school in
education uh we'll do the same for the
ukrainian children we've done the same
for hong kongers um i think that's
important but this rwanda deal is really
important because we've got to break the
business model of these criminals we've
you know we can't israel had a deal with
them didn't they and and it and it just
didn't work well it's a very different
it was
not like our deal people compare us to
the australia deal and israel this is
very different and i think it's the
right thing to do um i absolutely
believe that you know we have to make
sure we send a very clear message to
people that it won't pay don't come here
come across illegally no come here
legally right back to my own story okay
right we fled iraq from saddam hussein
came straight here to a safe country
these people are coming from france
that's what i'm saying you know you were
privileged enough to be able to fly here
because people have to get on dingies
that sink in
they're in france they're in a safe
country they don't have circles on that
one i need to ask you about india before
we run out of time um are you complete
the prime minister there this morning of
course are you completely comfortable
doing a deal with a country that refuses
to condemn russia at the u.n and the
behavior of putin well india is the
world's largest democracy they are
neutral um on this they know what our
position is the prime minister's taking
a leadership position um in um
making sure we we defend uh the rights
of the ukrainian people they have been
illegally attacked invaded war crimes
are being committed in the ukraine the
indian government is very aware of
africa and yeah india still won't
condemn them well that india has chosen
a path of neutrality we i'm sure the
prime minister will make very clear what
what what our position is worse than
that they're still buying russian oil in
rupees at huge discounts um and they
obviously have weapons deals with
russian-made uh weaponry and um it's
undermining the sanctions that that the
most of the western world is trying to
implement
you mentioned uh weapons so around 65 of
the indian
military uh hardware is russian
we want to change that we want to uh see
india
be looking at buying uh western uh um
defense weapons and other uh weaponry
that's part of the trade deal i also
mentioned talking about oil and it being
discounted um and
that is in part one of the reasons why
um our energy bills are increasing here
in the united kingdom but we think it's
the right thing to do and yet russia is
not um uh india is not doing that well
let's say look india is a world's
largest democracy they've taken it a
neutral position we have taken a very
different position i am certain the
prime minister
will will will be they they have in in
terms of you know the votes of the un
and
the position they've taken overall i
think our position is clear on the
illegality of the invasion of uh the
ukraine by uh putin
but they're propping up the putin regime
by doing this well and and this is
something that you know the prime
minister will be discussing really with
this account of course they will our
position is very clear but this trip is
about trade this trip is about you know
building that trade deep trade
relationship um with a country that will
be the third largest economy in the
world uh by 20. it's about doing a deal
with a country that's supporting the
putin regime that is hammering people
day and night in ukraine illegally well
i think that's a misrepresentation of
india's position in terms of you know
they've chosen a path at the moment of
of neutrality and i think um uh
we will make our position very clear i'm
sure the prime minister will will talk
about um uh you know why uh we have you
know led i hope you know with our uh u.s
and european uh uh colleagues on
supporting um the ukrainian people the
ukrainian people are um putting up a
really good fight um they're fighting
like lions in in the donbass this battle
for the donbass is going to be crucial
uh to re
i hope um uh reminding the prosecution
of of the errors of of judgment that
he's made as much to do as far as your
department is concerned as well are you
going to get more of your civil servants
back to work
we are um we have uh
been very clear uh that uh i want to see
uh departments going back to um you know
levels of of office occupancy that are
pre-pandemics so pre-pandemic working
now in saying that i also want my teams
out visiting you know nurseries early
years schools colleges and universities
and i think that's the right thing to do
but my absolute commitment is to make
sure that people come back i tell you
there's another good reason is that the
most junior staff can only really
progress if we are together uh whether
it be in uh sanctuary buildings in
london or in our you know great hub in
sheffield we've doubled the number of
people in sheffield we're up to 1500
people now in sheffield and other hubs
in darlington and elsewhere um so we
want people um uh back to pre-pandemic
levels of office um uh occupancy what's
that how quickly oh as soon as
we're we're on it now we're where people
are people are uh uh and i have to say
uh we've delivered on skills the skills
bill is with the you know imagination
you're ever running you're gonna get me
in trouble right
skills bill we've delivered on school's
white paper um to make sure every child
is entitled to a great school uh
wherever they live in the country and of
course family hubs and half of england's
local authorities okay and i can't end
this interview without wishing him
actually the queen a happy birthday
absolutely right thank you oh you've
lost the tl thing is that because
everybody thought it was tour leader no
it was it's t levels and i would have
put on but i've had too many badges i
thought it's important to actually have
the this this is one of those mods
exactly exactly good to see you as
always thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you
well the party gate row is once again on
many of the front pages this morning the
eye says that tory rebels fear a
backlash from voters due to the
controversy surrounding boris johnson's
recent fine for breaking lockdown rules
the guardian reports on the prime
minister's bid to block an inquiry into
whether he misled parliament over
partygate which it says has failed
on the front of the times the children's
commissioner says england should follow
wales and scotland and ban the smacking
of children
the telegraph goes with russia's test of
a new intercontinental ballistic missile
known as satan 2 which is said to carry
a dozen warheads
while the mail says prince harry is
being accused by royal staff of
breathtaking arrogance following his u.s
tv appearance
so as we know the prime minister is uh
in india on a trade deal uh we sent our
political editor beth rigby of course uh
to be with him hi beth a very good
morning to you hood what the minister
was saying that despite what's happening
with uh russia this deal will go ahead
if possible your thoughts this morning
good morning
hi kay well yeah you asked the education
secretary there didn't you about ukraine
quite extensively we asked the prime
minister about that too on the plane as
you said uh india has abstained on a
vote in the security council uh it has
failed to explicitly condemn the
invasion of ukraine well what did the
prime minister say about it on the plane
when we came over
he said that he
would address some of these issues with
prime minister modi who he will meet in
new delhi tomorrow
but he said
that the uk had to do this with india as
equal partners he said that he had to
recognize the historic relationship
between india
and russia and also recognize uh the
relationship historically between the uk
and india the uk being
a former colonial power perhaps the
indian government would not particularly
appreciate the uk government telling
them how to run their foreign policy so
it is a sensitive subject but the prime
minister was clear that he would
certainly ask prime minister modi or
talk to him at least about the
possibility of reducing india's
dependence on russian
military equipment and will of course
raise the matters of ukraine but in
quite a delicate way the second big
thing he wants to do here is that trade
deal both countries want to get that
done they hope to nail it down by the
end of the year both prime ministers
with an eye on the 2024 elections they
have respectively but it will be tough
uh on the uk's part they want to sell
more alcoholic spirits more cars and car
parts to india and india's part they
would probably like more visas now the
prime minister opened the door to that
on the plane saying that the uk needed
hundreds of thousands more workers but
that any immigration plan had to be
controlled so watch this space see what
they have to say on that i think we're
going to be hearing from the prime
minister quite a bit today as he tries
to keep the focus very much on what he's
doing in india and very much away from
what's going on back home okay beth
thanks very much thank you still to come
on the programme for you this morning
we'll speak to the author and journalist
robert hardman as the queen celebrates
her 96th birthday
unicef spokesperson in ukraine toby
fricker will be with us
from dinipro as the humanitarian crisis
worsens there
ahead of a vote on whether the pm should
be investigated for misleading
parliament will speak to former tory
cabinet minister david cook
senior ukrainian negotiators have
offered to hold talks with the russians
with russia i should say in mario paul
in a bid to evacuate troops and
civilians from the besieged port city
but a top putin ally claims that russian
forces will seize the mario pole steel
plant today the last major stronghold of
resistance in the city mario paul is
strategically significant because it
would help russia create a land bridge
with crimea
russian forces now control almost all of
the city with the last remaining
ukrainian troops holding on in the as of
style steelworks city authorities are
hoping to evacuate around six thousand
people through a humanitarian corridor
between mario paul
and zafiyah
i can't pronounce this one forgive me
zapier zazi there you go i know somebody
who can and that's deborah she's
standing by for us in kiev um hi uh
deborah good morning um so will these
talks go ahead or is mario paul about to
fall
that's a really good question it's it's
very unclear how anything good can come
out of mario paul at the moment it's a
city that's seen the worst of the
fighting and that's a pretty high bar
given how devastated other parts of the
country have been by russia's invasion
but yes you've got this
ally of president putin um saying that
he believes these the city will fall by
lunchtime today it's this last pocket of
resistance in this steel works where you
have ukrainian fighters who have been
holding out against the odds refusing to
give up if the city falls that would be
the largest city to fall to russia in
eight weeks of war and there is a belief
that russian forces are trying to
achieve successes for the kremlin by the
9th of may which is the annual victory
day marking the end of the second world
war and russia's defeat over the nazi
russia's victory rather over the nazis
but i was talking yesterday to a top a
top ukrainian official who doesn't
believe russia will achieve any
successes by that date
france's two remaining presidential
candidates clashed in their only
televised debate yesterday four days
before the country votes far-right
leader marine le pen still lags behind
the centrist emmanuel macron in the
polls but millions of voters remain
undecided
i believe that the veil is a uniform
imposed by the islamists i think the
young women wearing them are forced to
stop mixing things up do not give me a
lesson i'm not giving you a lesson
do not give me a lesson on how to
finance my plan
well joining us now is our international
affairs editor dominick wagon hi dom uh
how's it looking
well it's a pretty fiery debate i think
the the verdict coming out of last
night's debate is that le pen did better
than last time but not well enough to
change things last time in 2017 she was
tranced by emmanuel macron and that
cemented her defeat in the election that
followed this time around macron was
able to land punches on issues like the
hijab the muslim headscarf saying that
would cause a civil war in france but
also on the fact that le pen's party has
a loan from a russian bank and that was
damaging in the current climate and she
got flustered after that but regained
her composure her challenge k in this
election is to not come across as an
extremist on immigration and the eu both
issues that she hasn't really changed
her positions on but she's trying to
focus her fire on more populist issues
coming across as a champion of the
ordinary french person on issues like
the cost of living and economic issues
on those macron was able to unpick some
of her plans a little
saying you know how she going to pay for
them but she was able to i think stand
her ground his challenge is that to many
french he's an annoying arrogant
ex-banker and i think in his kind of
exasperation with her he will have come
across to many voters or some voters at
least is rather supercilious and and
snide and and uh condescending having
said that uh he has emerged the winner
in terms of the opinion polls six out of
ten uh french voters saying they thought
he was more convincing than uh le pen i
think you know the the consensus about
debates is they don't change much in
elections unless there's a big upset
that wasn't last night and therefore i
don't think this has done enough to
restore le pen's fortunes in this
election not not at the moment at least
and we should just explain briefly why
you are where you are this morning
yeah i'm in uh marine le pen's
constituency rather grand town hall
behind me the uh hotel de ville uh k and
the area around here is surrounded by
slag heaps it's a kind of fading
industrial area of northern france it's
where she has obviously enormous amount
of
support much better than
macron did in the first round of the
election so it's worse she's hoping to
sort of form her power base to try and
take the presidency as i say though it's
a pretty uphill task and i don't think
last night's debate has really done
enough to restore her fortunes
okay for now thank you
look uh looking out some of today's
other headlines for you now a new
official photo has been released by
buckingham palace to mark the queen's
96th birthday the picture was taken in
march in the grounds of windsor castle
on the queen's left is the pony a pony
by by beck nightingale and on her right
is by beck katie
almost 500 million pounds of taxpayers
money could have been wasted because the
government failed to monitor coronavirus
restrictions put in place for
international travel according to the
national audit office the report says
there was no system to judge the success
of measures such as the traffic light
system and passenger locator forms
israeli military said that its warplanes
struck a security post and part of an
underground site used to produce rocket
engines in gaza
the strike comes after a rocket launch
from the palestinian territory landed in
israel
an investigation into a fatal shooting
on the set of the alec baldwin movie
rost has found that there were willful
and serious breaches of gun safety rules
on set baldwin was pointing a gun at the
cinematographer helena hutchins while
preparing for a scene last october when
it went off killing her instantly
johnny depp has continued his testimony
in his defamation trial against amber
heard the actor described a toxic
relationship with his ex-wife who he
says abused him rather than the other
way around here's david blevins
relaxing to some reggae johnny depp
prepared for a second day in the witness
box but facing ex-wife amber heard in
the courtroom his testimony was far from
chilled out he recalled the moment she
found him drinking vodka in australia
where he was filming pirates of the
caribbean five
she then grabbed that bottle
and uh
and threw that
at me i honestly didn't i didn't feel
the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
the court was shown this photograph of
him in the emergency room and a more
graphic one of what he described as his
grotesque injury
the couple are suing each other depp
seeking 50 million dollars and heard 100
million over a washington post opinion
piece she wrote about domestic violence
he claimed he'd been the victim of abuse
at her hands and that her allegations
controlled his every waking second
previously the subject of a libel action
in london their toxic relationship is
now the talk of an american courtroom
david blevins sky news washington
there's more than one way isn't there to
be immortalized on your 96th birthday
the queen has been depicted as a very
own barbie doll to mark her platinum she
looks like helen mirren doesn't she her
platinum jubilee by toymaker mattel it's
part of the tribute collection which
honors visionary individuals with an
outstanding impact and legacy the line
launched last year starting with a doll
of the american actress lucille ball
here's lucy here's her majesty
let's kick off with the express in the
papers which shows a very stylish barbie
doll as well of the queen made in honor
of her platinum jubilee that we've just
been talking about as you can see picked
up in the papers
are the headlines for you
there you go this is an image from the
telegraph which depicts a bit of a
disagreement between two birds as an
angry dunnuk decided to attack a green
finch with its sharp tunnels
you can see that not happy at all
and finally the mail features a very
clever gold retriever dog owners managed
to strike it rich after his puppy
dug up some ancient gold coins valued at
around six thousand pounds calling him a
good
our boy stories for you this morning
defiant under pressure boris johnson
arrives in india saying he intends to
fight the next election as conservative
leader
ukraine has called for special
negotiations with russia to evacuate its
forces from mariopol along with the last
remaining civilians
and the two final presidential
candidates clash on tv before france
goes to the polls
[Music]
a little earlier i asked the education
secretary why the government wants to
delay a vote over the prime minister's
partygate conduct nadim zahawi told me
it's about following due process
if you want to follow due process then
you allow the police to complete their
investigation you allow the sue grey
report to be published and then the
privilege committee can look at that
that is what i'll be voting for today
the amendment is the right chronology
and the right way to follow due process
or you could just be the prime minister
and say you know what
i'll just refer myself to the privileges
committee and then all of this nonsense
that we're debating and taking up all my
valuable time i'll just put it in train
but there is a police investigation yeah
there is already cabinet officers
which is already reported in some scale
well but we haven't seen the we've seen
the bridge version right we haven't seen
this we've seen at least 50 fines and
all i'm saying to you is due process is
the right thing
ukrainian tennis star alina
jackie's going to do this better than me
i don't know where my teeth are this
morning switzerland has told sky news
that russian and bella russian players
should be allowed to compete at
wimbledon if they speak out against the
war players and administrators have
criticized the all england club's
decision to stop them competing at this
year's tournament
i gave you um a clue who's there for us
this morning jackie is all over it for
us jackie good morning
good morning kay uh yes alina
switzerlina uh is the player that you
that you were talking about who sent us
a very strong message last night now
this decision by wimbledon uh affects
five of the male top 100 players
including the world number two daniel
medvedev it also affects 12 of the top
100 women including the world number
four arena zabalenka and were keen to
point out they're not against the
players this is not personal this is to
stop uh russia using success at the
championships to promote their regime uh
the lta also followed suit they're on
tennis association banning all the
players russian players and belarusian
players from the warm-up event so queens
and eastbourne there will be no russians
in any of the events on grass this
summer now the atp the world governing
body of the men's tour and the wta the
world governing body of the women's tour
have come out and strongly uh condemned
wimbledon for this decision they say
they do not agree with it the atp said
it was unfair the wta said they were
disappointed now in their statement
the atp said this has the potential to
set a damaging precedent
for the game and discrimination against
players based on nationality was a
violation of their agreement with
wimbledon because it should be based on
ranking and merit and uh the the women's
tour said pretty much the same thing now
there has been criticism from some
players novak djokovic the world number
one has come out and labeled it a crazy
decision overnight and uh we've been
hearing from the top ukrainian player
elena svitolina she sent me this message
uh last night uh there was a joint
message on social media from all the
ukrainian players yesterday saying they
don't want a total ban on russian and
belarusian players what they do want is
for them to publicly to come out and
condemn the war
i think
as we also made a statement today uh
from ukrainian tennis players uh the
best way would be not to bend completely
but
make
them speak about
the war in ukraine to ask them if they
support the invasion in ukraine if they
support their government and if they can
answer those questions if they
say that they don't support it they
don't support putin they don't support
lukashenko then they would be allowed to
to participate
they haven't spoken out because you know
they're terrified of what might happen
to either themselves or their families
it remains to be seen what will happen
next will the atp take further action
against wimbledon
okay thank you
now ukrainian officials have reached out
to russia to open a humanitarian
corridor in order to evacuate 6 000
women children and elderly people from
the besieged city of mariopol
joining us now is unicef spokesperson in
ukraine toby fricker is in denipro um hi
toby thanks for joining us on the
program this morning what is the
situation at the moment how important is
this uh potential humanitarian corridor
uh for the people of mariopol
yeah i mean the the humanitarian
corridor and that safe passage out for
civilians for children is absolutely
critical uh i mean they're stuck in
areas of extremely heavy fighting people
are in basements for days for weeks and
hours and months on end
and they need to get out they need to
get to safety you know i've met children
at the intensive care unit in zapatica
which is a town uh southeast south of
dinipro where i am now and you know a
four-year-old boy who was injured trying
to get out of an area of heavy fighting
himself uh so people need that guarantee
that they can get safe passage out and
they need to get out as quickly as
possible
um
if they don't what's going to happen
we've seen images of
civilians literally cowering below the
uh those steel works
yeah i mean the consequence uh obviously
horrific i mean the fighting goes on the
lack of food there's a lack of running
water in fact 1.4 million people across
east ukraine do not have access to
running water
so they're seeking out dirty water
sources there are risks of disease
outbreaks um and so the consequences are
horrific on young lives on children's
lives so whoever is stuck there and
whoever wants to get out needs to have
that safe passage so that we can reach
them with you first of all with medical
uh support as soon as we can but also
with what's called the sort of
psychological first aid given the the
trauma that that clearly they're going
through
what does that involve
well it involves providing counselling
involves providing emotional support it
involves providing some form of
childhood again and that means playing
that means a space for some relief
but the first thing is to get people out
safely
secondly to make sure those people who
come out are well enough and have the
medical support they need and then it's
also start to rebuild their lives as
much as we can while the war goes on
across the country
we're talking about mario paul but of
course city after city after city has
found itself in a similar position
hasn't it
yeah that's right unfortunately the you
know the war in the east is particularly
uh concerning it's intensifying but also
we've seen your attacks in la vie in
other parts of the the country you know
i met a mum
with her two-year-old alice in uh levied
in the hospital in the beaver and she'd
been underground in the carcave metro
cargive is a city in the north that's
been under attack and they spent 32 days
in the metro there uh fortunately unicef
and our local partners were able to
provide some game some fun in the metro
station for kids who are stuck down
there and providing some sort of
psychological support but she spent you
know 32 days that's that's a horrific
amount of days being under the ground
and her child had previously had some
cancer surgery was very weak already and
was in hospital now trying to recover
from that ordeal
yeah i remember seeing firsthand the
work of uh unicef after the uh in sri
lanka actually after the tsunami back at
the start of of this century and it's
the games that you send out and and the
little uh welfare packs that these kids
get that can actually make all the
difference to them isn't it
yeah that's right it's about providing
some form of childhood again a normality
for children who are caught in the
horrors of war i mean that the trauma is
massive and every day that fear that
uncertainty of what's going to happen is
horrendous so it's just trying to
provide some normality again wherever
you can
but also the critical needs that they
have and that means access to water
obviously food
and also like i said that psychological
support as well um and then you know
education you're trying to bring back
some form of learning informal learning
online learning as quickly as you can to
get that sort of normality back
okay good to talk to you thanks tony
keep safe where you are there thank you
now let's get more on the queen's 96th
birthday which uh she is celebrating
today uh maddie is standing by for us
this morning at buckingham palace as you
can see hi maddie um 96 today we've seen
a fantastic photograph over that was
taken
last month
how is she going to celebrate her
birthday
good morning kay yes there is that
lovely photograph of her with the two
buyback ponies
nightingale and katie there's also a
barbie doll that's been released of the
queen to mark uh her 96th birthday her
and full long white gown the tiara she
wore when she got married the ceremonial
regalia she's actually spending her
birthday at the sandringham estate um in
the cottage which was said to be loved
by her um husband prince philip because
it's so close to the sea but in london
later in hyde park at 12 o'clock there
will be a 42 gun salute um and then
again at one o'clock the royal artillery
honorable artillery company sorry will
fire a 62 gun salute from tower wharf so
we expect um some that uh the band will
be playing happy birthday to her majesty
and a bit of um
uh pomp and ceremony there this is just
a precursor the full um
celebrations later this summer will be
for her jubilee so it's more laid-back
and low-key today those two uh gun
salutes and the band playing for her
okay that's great it's good to see you
thank you very much indeed love your new
jacket thank you maddie
now as the war in ukraine continues
ukrainians are finding new ways to
express their sorrow have a look at this
an award-winning ukrainian soprano has
been singing in japan for two decades
and is dedicating her latest series of
concerts to peace admission is free but
the crowds
are asked to give donations for water
food and medicine for ukraine
ahead of a vote on whether the pm should
be investigated for misleading
parliament will speak to former tory
justice minister david gawk
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news the
prime minister has landed in india
hoping to leave the partygate scandal
behind him the pm insists he won't
resign after being fined by police for
breaking his own lockdown rules or put
himself forward for a confidence vote or
put himself forward to be investigated
by other mps so what is david gork
former lord high chancellor of britain
former justice secretary former
conservative mp think about all of that
mr good morning to you thank you for
joining us um pm says in fact via his
minister this morning that it's the
natural order to wait until the other
two investigations have finished and
then he'll put himself forward for
investigation uh by the committee here
in the house of commerce
i think the motion that has been put
forward looks entirely reasonable i
think it's an entirely reasonable time
to vote upon it
the motion is saying that the
investigation by the privileges
committee
shouldn't begin until the police
have fully reported until the sugree
report
has been published but it seems
perfectly reasonable to make the
decision that there should be such an
investigation
at this point and i think the difficulty
for conservative mps is if they are seen
to vote this down
okay there might be a promise that
there'll be another vote at a later
stage but clearly the intention of the
government is not to hold such an
investigation
and conservative mps who vote it down
today
can be accused of trying to cover up
this issue of trying to protect the
prime minister from an investigation
when clearly an investigation
is appropriate given that the prime
minister has already been found to have
broken his own lockdown laws
and what parliament needs to understand
properly is whether he has misled
parliament as well
you're a learned man uh there's been a
lot of comparison between a partygate
fine and a parking fine being comparable
um is it
no it's not uh and we have to remember
that this you know let's go back to the
point at which these offences uh may
have occurred at that point the
government including the prime minister
was stressing that this was of very
great importance that we all needed to
play our part that this was all about
you know protecting lives and that's why
those rules were in place so i think to
dismiss these as as as minor issues
given
the nature of the
lockdown rules
given that the public messages that were
coming from the government at the time
given that it was the prime minister
himself who decided to impose these
restrictions
i think the idea that he should just be
dismissed as as very minor offenses are
not really significant
and also
there is this issue here of what the
prime minister has said to parliament
and the accusation of uh misleading
parliament now it doesn't matter you
know if the prime minister had stood up
and said you know i've never
committed a parking offense and he had
that would be a serious matter because
you you just can't mislead parliament
he says as you well know and i'll put it
to you again that on the two occasions
that he allegedly misled parliament
at that time that's what he believed and
we can't disprove that we don't know
what was in his head at the time
well i think that's
the argument about whether he has
mislead parliament or not and that is
what the privileged privileges committee
uh committee made up of members of
parliament should investigate um i i
think there comes a point
maybe maybe it doesn't apply in the case
of the
birthday party uh but there comes a
point where if it is so obvious that it
is a party where there is so much
evidence that there are drinks there
that there are nibbles there maybe music
is playing yeah we don't entirely know
we don't have all the information yet um
but if the evidence is so
clear that in fact you know it looked
like a party it sounded like a party
um then you know it is a party and it's
not credible for the prime minister to
claim otherwise and the thought
otherwise but that's that's for the
committee to investigate and i think it
is right that it investigates that
specifically focused on the issue of
whether he has mislead parliament as
well but isn't the point
one that you just touched on there that
we don't know yet what all the evidence
is so why are we um hang drawn and
quartering him when we don't actually
know what either the police or sue gray
have concluded
because the this uh this motion that the
labour party has put forward isn't
calling for him to be
hanged drawn or quartered um what it's
saying is there should be an
investigation i think there is enough
evidence there
given the police's conclusion in terms
of uh the the the so-called birthday
party that there's a need for an
investigation
and what conclusions should be reached
should be based on the evidence and as i
say we're not talking about this
investigation commencing until the
police process has been completed
but i think it is reasonable at this
point for parliament to make it clear
that the evidence is sufficient that it
is of such seriousness that there should
be an investigation
but i agree the investigation shouldn't
start until the police have completed
their process
and the evidence can then be put before
the privileges committee
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you
thank you
now an investigation into a fatal
shooting on the set of the alec baldwin
movie rust has found that there were
willful and serious breaches of gun
safety rules on set baldwin was pointing
a gun at the cinematographer helena
hutchins while preparing for a scene
last october when it went off killing
her our us correspondent martha kellner
has this report
it was a tragedy which rocked the film
industry horrifying even in an animated
reenactment now an official
investigation has found the producers of
the film rust including alec baldwin
were responsible for the death of
cinematographer helena hutchins a report
by the state of new mexico where the
film was being recorded said producers
willfully violated rules showing a plain
indifference to employee safety rus
production
failed in their obligation to provide a
workplace free of recognized hazards
more specifically
there were several management failures
and more than sufficient evidence to
suggest
that if standard industry practices were
followed the fatal shooting of helena
hutchins and the serious injury to joel
souza would not have occurred
alec baldwin has previously said he
didn't pull the trigger on the gun that
he didn't know how a live bullet came to
be on this set that is still subject of
a criminal investigation but the film's
producers were found to have ignored
safety warnings and fined the maximum
amount of 136 thousand dollars
camera assistant lane looper had sounded
the alarm as he explained in an
interview with sky news last year i've
never felt more unsafe
on set
or offset you know
i have never been i've never felt i was
more in danger of dying on the set or on
the drive home because i was exhausted
mr lupa showed us a letter he wrote to a
production manager before hutchins death
he cautions of two accidental firearms
discharges his warnings the report found
went unheeded
if producers had abided by national
standards for firearm safety on film
sets investigators said helena hutchins
would most likely still be alive a slice
of accountability maybe but for her
husband and young son the awful
confirmation that her death was
preventable martha kellner sky news
all today's top stories coming up for
you at the top of the hour before that
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days will be mainly drive
cooler than recently but there'll be a
few showers around mostly fine now with
a patchy grand frost in the north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still ahead in the next hour of the
program for you this thursday morning
here on the breakfast show on sky the
education secretary has defended the
government's decision to seek a delay on
a vote on whether the pm should be
investigated for allegedly misleading
parliament we'll bring you reaction from
labour at the top of the next hour and
also the leader of the liberal democrats
uh davey will be with us as well and
then a little bit later on after that in
the following hour i've got a treat for
you that
relates to little mix stay tuned and
find out more
[Music]